hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the virtual world
I've got my vive and I've got my space
all set up and ready to go to scare the
everliving pants out of me because I've
got a horror game here called don't
knock twice and it's been a long long
time since I've been back and the
virtual world the world ooh
hey I got one heck of a pointer here my
wedding ring doesn't seem to fit me
quite row ah that is mildly
disconcerting I am completely untethered
I've got no strings to hold me down
wibble D wobble D so what that means is
I can go wherever I want to be able to
fight the demons at my back oh hi you
are not smoking before I went blind okay
don't you know that smoking can kill you
alright whatever alright let's do this
okay alright hey wow you are pretty
what a pretty goat you got there you
seem to be bulbous and Oh
Balthus okay alrighty I'm gonna walk
slowly towards ya calmly like an animal
whisperer I'm just gonna like caress
your sweet luscious lip here we go oh oh
oh
ah I can walk around to explore well let
why let me walk with my human legs ah
yes
whoo okay a map on and a floor and
release the telephone Blanc
sure wish dosa those cages would stop
squawking so I could hear myself think
huh that'd be great
press one to grab note from letterbox
all right okay whew what are we have
here press to read the note I'm already
reading it what oh I can read it one
knock to wake her from her bed twice to
raise her from the dead oh that oh
that's well that's well that's
unpleasant alright okay alright I think
I understand one hey wait alright here
let me get something straight here you
want me to knock this door whoa hey [ __ ]
off with you so what but what you're
telling me is that the whole name of the
game is don't knock twice and you're
telling me to knock twice right right
there's no demons in here is there okay
all right you know what whoa hey whoa
easy there
Oh wha a play by your rules
Oh No
yeah okay I don't like that I don't like
that I don't like that I don't like that
especially a don't like that I really
don't like that okay here we go hello Oh
I said Hey all right get in my combat
stance just in case anything needs to be
approached
leave me the food loon Chloe well am i
Chloe are you okay
that's floaties the phone is now in your
pocket you can grab it in I don't think
it is you know I let me grab hand like
I'm just I'm just gonna grab that phone
okay got it okay all right to my pocket
now barely stated in the southern edge
of Welsh valleys lies a stunning example
of understated architecture I'm bored
already is that going in my pocket I
hope not lame duck my head in the fire
for a second air Oh
roasting my chestnuts please no one
under there all right I better not be
knowing under there that's all I gotta
say about that oh yeah no I was right
about my original assumption I hate that
that is awful okay
what do we got here whoa pick up the
candlestick to illuminate your way this
candlestick ain't lit there's one thing
I know about this candle
what the Frick was that
someone got a cold over there all right
well whoosh I said wash all right all
good I got an achievement for that good
thing I'm so skilled at game I dropped
it
okay you know what I got me and Lou
Mayer here I'll kick you oh that's a
different knock location than I thought
it'd be y know I don't I know I said I
really don't want to oh I see what looks
like hair over there and that's a
problem I have with you
Oh God oh oh god oh god I don't want it
I don't want this you don't want this I
don't want this hello ah hello okay [ __ ]
off you you a guy drop a candle [ __ ]
dill weed bag dick who's there hello
hello okay we got four squeaking
squeaking oh oh oh oh
Wow Wow
hello not sure what that is okay I'm
just gonna carry on with my day hey JA
oh well that's in my pocket now okay let
me go over to the oh oh that's not good
ah Hirata mole okay okay all right
anyone at this one
hello sorry excuse me sorry hello well
that's a weird whatever that was
can I go out the door or something gonna
be oh okay alright that I didn't expect
that to just be open I know
grandmas at you oh boy my phone hello
why did you turn the power off I hate
you what I don't care what didi is not
playing why do you think I care that
right now oh I did I didn't turn the
power off water how would I have any
control over that Chloe grandma oh boy I
hate this
oh I hate I hate this oh I hate this ah
oh this is the worst thing a flu shot
got it
are you all was that ah now shut up
I'm a bibliophile oh the story behind
the artist just
oh oh okay
I don't like no I'm I don't want no I
don't I don't want that hello is that a
ghost baby seems like it might be a
ghost baby don't open I can't just I
can't figure out oh ah ghost baby okay
all right okay all right sir man
I don't want any hey-oh
I said no I said no I said no wait wait
hang on wait everybody wait okay go back
hang on foosh got it I'm fighting the
darkness with my powers of light and
love give me one of you bibliophile a
that's me
Department of Health and Social Services
Division of Child lay there not child
labor that'd be a weird department foosh
man loo mare sure is spreading his seed
mm I'm gonna go up big nope on that one
there big nope big nope nah no don't
have my coat can't possibly go out there
hole boy and that is not a thing I'm
gonna be doing today
there's absolutely not a thing I'm gonna
be doing okay it's a thing I'm gonna be
doing here we go let's do this thing
Oh outside you know that's oh yeah hate
it okay all right hate it all right very
much why why though but why why oh well
I dropped it please I really want it
there we go
hey who why and Wow okay hey I know how
to do this now Wow do I have a thumbs up
and that'd be nice
whoa hi okay that's really weird
what what hi
what you're gonna dump me again aren't
you you selfish [ __ ] wait that doesn't
make any sense
wait what that's not good I don't Khloe
what is what that doesn't what what
Chloe that doesn't make any sense what
can't we talk in person I have a weird
man job I have a weird mansion okay all
right okay what are we up here
scooch-scooch-scooch abou ch
who's in there who's in there we'll go
back inside maybe that one's open hello
I yell into my own house whatever where
apparently Chloe is whoa what the hell
all right well I'm that I didn't do none
of that
that was not me oh wow that's
terrifically broken
whoo Schmidt no apparently not okay you
know what oh I'll come back later on
that I'll come back later that's that's
no bueno at all all right all right
why why why would you do that don't do
that just don't do that whoosh
bibliophile
mm uh she dumped me okay all right she
dumped me all those years ago and now
she just waltzes back into my life and
expects to carry on like everything's
okay well it's not I just wish she left
me the [ __ ] alone
she's trying to WoW me with her fancy
job with a big house but there's no
hiding the true she abandon me and can't
stop hating for that we're strangers now
she's not fit to be the mother a mother
and she'll probably to send me back to
the homeland tired of me all right wait
where am i by the way we're Wow nope all
right well how about we don't do that
hmm how about we don't do any of what
you're thinking of doing and how about I
I go back and light the fire in the
fireplace can you open okay ooh all
right okay I hate that Oh blood great
blood wonderful why is there blood why
would there be that thing that's on the
ground there I asked the air oh that's
why I hate this everything about this is
everything I hate okay all right well
that's um [ __ ] that's bad oh okay all
right
ah I am officially terrified so yeah I'm
gonna well leave this one here I'm
scared I'm legitimately scared this is
terrifying um but this seems like a
longer game so if you guys want to see
more of this let me know because I'll
finish it I will but I hate it
very scary so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
think down the comments below and as
always see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]